your heart races and your cheeks begin
to flush as you anticipate the surge of
energy this wind will bring you move to
the edge of your seat you can't get
enough so why are we so passionately
involved or obsessed with sports
hormones control the way we feel and are
stimulated by every action we take
hugging a friend releases oxytocin
making you feel calm while cramming for
an exam releases cortisol leading to
irritability but also alertness simply
watching sports stimulates hormone
levels as well testosterone in
particular is a hormone linked to
dominance and social interaction but
also increases brain power spatial
awareness and muscle growth and
scientists have found that after
watching your team win levels of
testosterone skyrocket especially
compared to experiencing a loss funnily
enough this has even been documented in
politics during the 2008 US election
males who voted for Obama were found to
have much higher levels of testosterone
after he won than those who voted for
McCain when your favorite athlete takes
home the gold a surge of dopamine is
also released this biological rush
activates pleasure centers in the brain
while increasing memory and learning
this increased memory helps explain why
some people continue to watch sports
they're looking to recreate the
physiological excitement they can't seem
to forget the brain also contains cells
called mirror neurons which are not only
activated when completing an action but
also when viewing it or even hearing it
certain mirror neurons will be activated
when throwing a ball seeing someone
throw a ball or even hearing the word
ball it's the reason we can put
ourselves in another's shoes and why we
experience a similar emotional and
physical reaction to somebody else
winning in fact scientists monitoring
both athletes and spectators see the
same parts of the brain activated as if
the viewer were playing the game from an
evolutionary perspective this allows us
to understand the mental states of
others and interpret their actions and
intentions as well as empathize with
them it also helps to explain why we
find such pleasure and excitement in
seeing our favorite team or athlete
become a champion curiously scientists
have found that some people have
problems with this mirror neuron system
this renders I'm unable to empathize
with others leading to some social
disorders at the extreme ends serial
killers have been found to lack this
mirror neuron system science says our
obsession with sports may be a great
example of our adapted hormonal and
neuronal systems at
work keeping us connected as the human
race while watching humans race don't
forget we have a new video out every day
during the Olympics but if you can't
wait head to cbc.ca slash Olympics slash
sign says for more keep asking those
burning questions with the hashtag
science says and subscribe for more
awesome science videos